[Music]
math is really beautiful but many
students don't ever get a chance to see
it
because we hide that beauty until way
too late in a math students educational
experience we're hiding a whole amazing
areas of mathematics until the students
reach College
but many of the students don't make it
that far they decide before they get
there that there's nothing to see here
they say they're not a math person
because they're bored with math because
they've been taught that math is
arithmetic
they haven't been taught that math is
Discovery math is a creative discipline
I know a lot of artistically creative
people the most creative people I know
though are mathematicians you know they
have to create new Frameworks in which
to create new knowledge they're creating
Castles in the Sky
[Music]
Richard russick I'm the founder of art
of problem solving we develop
educational resources and opportunities
for students who are really interested
in learning
I did not learn very much in the
classroom we didn't have the internet
then so there was no you know there was
no YouTube to watch videos but I learned
a lot from textbooks and working on
problems I had a stack of formula sheets
and I would just memorize them and I
would eventually get to a training
program for the students who did well in
a series of national competitions I'm
there for five weeks I see 50 or 60
problems during this time and I got
exactly zero
correct I had to go back to those
formulas and ask why is this true why is
that true and realize that I did not
know and had to start trying to prove
some of these things
I was coming out of a high school that
Northern Alabama it was an aggressively
average high school but I go off to
Princeton I'm worried about competing
against students that went to the magnet
school private schools and I found in
the first few weeks it was very clear
that I had it backwards I had training
they didn't have
and that training was all those years
staring at problems I didn't know how to
do and having to learn how to fight
through them I had learned how to take
basic ideas and solve really difficult
problems and I could transfer that
General skill into physics into computer
science into engineering into economics
into philosophy
we're training kids to compete with
computers this is what computers do they
get it right every time and when we
train kids to compete with those
computers we're setting them up for
failure I think this is part of the
problem is this is the way that they are
evaluated
so we need to bring these challenges
earlier we need to put students in these
situations where they're not going to be
able to get it right the first time or
the second time or the third time and
the kids know how to handle that we
train it out of them you look at kids
when they're four I mean four-year-old
kid can't do anything but they'll try
they'll fail they'll cry they'll run off
to their room and then they'll do
something really amazing they'll come
back really quickly and they'll try
again because therefore and they haven't
learned yet how to quit forever
learning's hard it is painful yeah it's
a little frustrating but you're getting
somewhere that's that's the sign that
you are finally getting somewhere with
whatever you're trying to learn is when
you're feeling this kind of discomfort
if you're comfortable you're not
learning anything I think one of the
things that making this transition to
fighting through the problems as opposed
to just knowing how to do it when I look
at it is understanding that it's a
process and not an accumulation of
knowledge it's about being more playful
looking at the problem and trying to
learn about the situation remove a few
constraints from the problem and explore
or add constraints to the problem and
explore a little bit what we don't do is
show them how to do it
and then say okay this is how we did
this problem here's another one that's
similar so we'll show them a problem
we'll work through it together like if
they get completely stuck we'll kind of
guide them a little bit and then come
back and summarize at the end and say
hey look at this General strategy we
used you can motivate the steps towards
that and then they'll have another tool
in their toolkit I don't think of myself
as teaching math I think of myself as
teaching students problem solving and by
problem solving I mean teaching students
how to solve problems they've never seen
before and math is a really powerful way
to teach that
I think a lot of it is modeling for the
student the questions we eventually want
the student to learn to ask themselves
instead of saying oh you just add the
seven and three here's why what we do is
walk them through the questions that one
might ask themselves in order to figure
out how to do the thing
we found that there were a lot of
students out there for whom textbooks
were not sufficient so we started with a
community where we could just bring the
kids together online and then we started
building online learning systems
adaptive Learning System where you just
give the students problems and lead them
into harder and harder material and I
started developing videos to go along
with the Adaptive Learning System we
have two online schools now we have
Learning Centers we have an online
community that is hundreds of thousands
of Learners from all over the world our
textbooks our comic books a lot of
students are visual Learners and a lot
of mathematical information can be
conveyed really effectively visually
we use it for pedagogical reasons as
well you can't lecture a third grader
but in a comic book you can simulate
conversations we can model some of the
strategies we want them to use we can
model students asking questions we can
model students working through
challenges we can model students being
wrong and being okay with that
[Music]
they're readily accessible to those who
have the means to pay for them and those
who have parents who know to look for
them Meanwhile we're removing a lot of
these opportunities from schools the set
of students who are getting involved in
these programs is getting narrower and
narrower so as a result our country has
a much narrower pool of people who are
going into advanced math and science the
next step in our evolution is learning
how to work closely with schools where
the delivery mechanism there is the most
important person the student is working
with in their educational experience
during the day which is their teacher so
there we're trying to learn how we are
going to learn how to work with teachers
in the classroom to empower them to give
their students the experience we give
our students so we're going to go and
find that Talent ourselves by going into
the schools so that we can reach those
students who don't have the means or the
knowledge to look for opportunities
outside the classroom we need to be
drawing Talent from across our entire
population
[Music]